[موسيقى]
كانت الشريحة
إحدى السمات الرئيسية
لجناحنا بالتأكيد أنها مستوحاة من ضجة قديمة جدًا
يتم تنظيمها على أساس سنوي
في لوكسمبورغ وهي ما يسمى بـ
shubapawa وهي تقليد قديم
جدًا وواحد من  أقدم معارض ترفيهية في العالم ،
لذلك كان بالنسبة لنا عنصرًا لإنشاء
تجربة لا تُنسى ، وخاصة
في نهاية جناحنا ،
لذا فقد جاء الإلهام لجناح لوكسمبورج
هنا في إكسبو 2020 دبي من
قبل المهندسين المعماريين الاستوديو في لوكسمبورج
الذي نظروا إليه بالفعل  موضوع
المعرض الذي أردنا تحقيقه في
لوكسمبورغ الواسع الحيلة وقد توصلوا
إلى هذه الفكرة الرائعة لاستخدام
شريط موبيوس الذي يعد نوعًا من
البنية الرياضية اللانهائية التي
تمثل الاقتصاد اللانهائي وكذلك الاقتصاد الدائري.
مع العلامة التجارية لأمتنا الجديدة ، أردنا
أن نعطي ثلاث سمات لوكسمبورغ
تضعنا في مكانة دولة
مفتوحة  تصنيفنا كأمة ديناميكية
وأيضًا شريك موثوق به وكل هذه
العناصر الثلاثة يمكنك بالتأكيد
رؤيتها في الهيكل الرائع
لجناحنا
أولاً ، لدينا منطقة انتظار ، لذلك قمنا
بتصميم
اختبار قصير حيث
يمكن للزائر أن يخمن
أسئلة مختلفة تتعلق
بالحقائق الممتعة في لوكسمبورغ ،
ثم يتم الترحيب بالزائر من قبل
دوقنا الكبير ، لذا فإن رئيس
دولتنا بعد أن تأخذ رحلتك أو
تبدأ رحلتك على منحدر
ينقلك إلى فتحة رائعة
داخل المبنى حيث
سيكتشف الزائر الموارد الخمسة التي
اعتبرنا أنها
حتمية لتقديمها باعتبارها
رفاهية الحيلة ، سيكون العنصر الأول هو
التنوع ، وثاني
اتصال نقفز إلى الاستدامة مباشرة
بعد التوجه إلى عرضنا الرئيسي
حيث ستختبر لوكسمبورغ باعتبارها
دولة جريئة وجزءًا مغامرًا
ومن ثم الدخول في  الفناء الداخلي
حيث نقف هنا
وحيث تكتشف الجمال  y من
طبيعة لوكسمبورغ
[موسيقى]
أنت